[Music]
the idea behind interactive origami is
that we want to make robot users
customized and easier to create for
people who are not necessarily trained
in engineering design and so we
basically designed the system which
allows people to do this design very
intuitively their two main ideas behind
it one is Eevee fabrication and one is
being able to virtually verify that your
robot will work once it's abrogated on
the fabrication side we've been using 3d
printing and folding techniques in order
to make the fabrication very easy and on
the functionality side we've
incorporated simulations in order to
make sure that the robot can actually
walk and can actually perform does
3d printing has a lot of advantages you
can print very complex structures
they're very rigid
whereas in 2d fabrication it's very fast
and you can create basically lightweight
but still strong structures we took the
advantage of both of them and we decided
to 3d print 2d patterns so this allowed
us to get very rapid fabrication of
structures that are still slightly so
designing a robot is challenging because
there are many aspects that must be
designed you have the 3d shape the
motion the electronics the control
software so how do you allow a casual
user of any skill level to design all of
these aspects at the same time to create
a robot that will solve the users tasks
using our system users can create a
robot body by simply mixing and matching
parts from an existing catalog and in
the same way the user designs a motion
for the robot by selecting from a list
of suggestions and modifying the motion
parameters and all of the models design
of the system can be directly fabricated
and they are guaranteed to work in the
real world so what makes interactive
robot gommi powerful is that it helps
users in designing robots that will
perform tasks well by guiding users in
improving both the motion and the
geometry of the robot design for
instance making the robot faster or more
stable or decreasing the fabrication
cost to make them more affordable what
we've put into the database there are a
lot of wheeled robots and somebody drove
up you could combine anywhere you want
in the database with any other priors
into as complex the structures you want
our system would help you make that
design functional what we envision for
the future is that a user would be able
to go into the system and basically
define the behavior of this robot in
terms
of tasks you can very quickly design a
tool that you can print out and that
will help you do these tasks very
cheaply very quickly very easily so the
dream is that this tool was enable
robots to become prevalent in our
everyday lives since the system is
geared towards making design easy making
fabrication easy then it's basically
lowering the barrier to having everybody
designed and create their own robot
[Music]
you